talk about silly role models thank you
and thanks oh it's been a great workshop
so far and I'm gonna be talking about
using semi random models to argue about
robustness for a couple of unsupervised
learning problems dictionary learning of
sparse coding and clustering mixtures of
gaussians which you've seen already in
this workshop so these are both based on
joint works that brands will ever see
who's at Rutgers University as this
audience probably knows very well
already promising models are extremely
popular when you are trying to find
structure in unlabeled data and mixtures
are gaussians used for clustering points
Lda is your topic modeling and so on so
forth
and here we generally assume that we are
given data that is generated from this
nice model this ideal model and you want
to design an algorithm that either
estimates the parameter system is the
density and so on and so forth and so
this is the vanilla setup and of course
I mean the advantages of this kind of
problem chick modeling I said there's a
very well-defined ground truth or a
planted solution and you can develop a
very rich theory around it word
identifiability getting efficient
algorithms and and so on but of course
the disadvantage is that real data
very rarely comes from this kind of an
idealized model and often the kind of
algorithms that people designed are not
necessarily robust to more than the
specification in errors and I guess
that's the whole point of this workshop
and I guess the main point of my talk in
some sense is to is to promote semi
random models as maybe a different way
of reasoning about robustness for many
of these problems I mean several models
have been studied a lot in computer
science and perhaps are not as popular
in statistics or machine learning and
maybe these are a good way to reason
about robustness for many of these
problems so what are several models so
what have you done in statistics our
machine learning is that you have a
generative model for the instance and
your instance is very well defined means
completely defined the generation
process is completely defined by the
model for instance mixture of gaussians
produces
a bunch of points that you won a cluster
of course the parameters are not known
and that's the goal
but it's the generation process
completely defined by the model on the
other end if you are talking about a
task like clustering in the worst case
you would assume nothing about the
points and you want in computationally
efficient algorithm for solving a
certain clustering problem and often
these problems tend to be np-hard so for
a semi random models seminar the models
are things that lie in between the two
okay so so there are random choices in
the generation but there are also some
adversarial choices okay so I guess you
could think of this two-phase character
and Batman as an analogy but really
there are these random choices but these
adversarial choices allow you to put in
more structure into the instance for
instance if you look at edit any graphs
as a good random model for your problem
additionally graphs don't have things
like large cliques or then sub graphs
and so on but you can put in more
adversarial choices to allow for this
kind of a structure which is usually
seen in real world class and 700 models
were studied first by Blum and Spencer
and they studied this in the context of
coloring but they've been a wide variety
of semi random models depending on the
kind of adversity of choices that you
are alone okay and I mean in this
generality you know you can capture many
many different models for instance you
could even capture things like the
epsilon contamination model of the
Hoover model that you studied and in
fact some of these works do do this for
some some of these combinatorial
problems and some of these semi-random
models are more general they talk about
general properties of average case
problems sorry average case models which
is all of you to prove algorithmic
guarantees but in this talk I'll focus
on one particular family of semi random
models and these are what are known as
monotone adversary's monotone adversary
models okay so here your semi random
model is
the generator model plus this monitor
adversary and what is this monitor an
adversary the first you draw your
instance from the usual PR generator
model and then this adversity can come
and then modify the instance but only in
a way that's helpful okay so we saw one
example for the case of matrix
completion and wrong stock but then you
could do various other I mean you have
various other models for different
problems and and their goal is that you
want to identify why do you want to
study these heavier models or more turn
adversity models you want to identify
robust algorithms that are not too
tailor-made for the problem okay so two
tailor-made for the model so these are
choices that are helpful in some ways
but you don't you want to identify
algorithms that are robust and not too
tailor-made for the model from things
that are not robust so you could think
about these monotone adversaries as I
mean being of two different kinds I mean
these are the kinds that have been
studied the first kind you could think
about these monotone adversaries as
improving some kind of a planted
solution okay so this is a little more
vague but you know let me give you an
example of it so here you know you have
this generative model for instance you
could think about a mixture of gaussians
or clustering or a stochastic block
model for partitioning or community
detection and so you have you know these
clusters which are not known to you and
there are many more edges inside these
clusters in between these clusters and
now a monotone adversity can come and
either add edges inside the clusters or
deleted this between the clusters okay
now why is this a monotone adversary
because really a goal was not about
learning the generator model your goal
was doing this task of partitioning and
these changes that you do are only
making the planted partitioning even
better okay so these kind of monotone
adversaries improve the planted solution
and this was studied by I mean the first
studied by Phi K Killian for graph
partitioning and then there have been
other works for various of the
clustering problems
okay and often you can show that
semi-definite programming is robust to
these kind of monotone adversaries okay
there is certain other algorithms it's
hard to reason about what they do when I
mean when you have these camera
monitoring adversaries recovering the
SPM so that's a good question so mmm
that is just resolved by Moira oh I see
right right right so good so when I say
the robust I guess it's often in the
common it's often when you are willing
to tolerate some slack in the constants
for recovery so yes it's not true it's
not clear that it will actually hit the
recovery limit that you can do when I
mean for weak recovery but it's clear
it's known that it doesn't achieve it
okay but it's not know where there is
there is some other algorithm yeah I
mean okay so I'm not sure about the weak
recovery regime but in the exact
recovery regime is well understood
yes I think some of these problems are
not as well understood for things like
the weak recovery of the gym and certain
other regions yes a good question yeah
that's always a display mode of feeling
yeah okay good so the second type of a
monotone University model is where you
actually provide more information okay
and that's the kind of model that Rong
was mentioning so here you have this
hidden signal or planet solution and
your motor turn adversity just gives you
more information okay about this hidden
signal so one example could be
compressive sensing where you have this
hidden case pass vector and you see
random measurements of these this case
pass vector and if you get K log and
random linear measurements you can of
course recover this case pass vector
okay and there are many algorithms to do
this but what if you are given more
information okay these are not random
linear measurements these are
potentially adversarial linear
measurements but it is only more
information so it should only help you
okay so linear programming you can show
that a
minimization linear programming works
because the same dual proof will go
through you have more constraints you
can choose to neglect those dual
variables okay but it's not clear that
lot of the other algorithms iterator
heuristics work and another example is
matrix completion again with strong
talked about here you have a matrix
which is low rank if you're given random
entries we know that there are many
algorithms at work what if you have
given more entries adversarially and
it's it's it's again easy to show that
convex relaxations work but alternating
minimization is a different story and
ron talked about it in the previous talk
ok so these are two kinds of monitoring
adversaries that have been studied and I
think these are nice ways of reasoning
about robustness for many of these
problems and in this talk we look at a
couple of other semi random models and
here we will talk about the several
models in the context of dictionary
learning and clustering make sure the
gaussians these are two problems where
convex relaxations have not been as
successful and so it seems more
challenging okay
the seminar models seem more challenging
in these contexts good so any questions
so far
so the first problem that we look at is
dictionary learning so some of you may
be familiar with this problem but let me
just introduce it so that we are all on
the same page so there's a very popular
statistical model when you are doing
representation learning for instance so
the main idea is that data a high
dimensional data is often sparse when
you look at it in the right places in
the right over complete basis and so
it's extremely useful in when you are
doing feature extraction finding nice
representations and so on so what's the
mathematical problem you're given as
input a matrix Y ok you should really
think about the columns of Y as the
vectors are columns of Y are the samples
that are given to you so there are s
samples of dimension and neat and the
way you've generated these vectors these
columns are y is as follows so there is
this hidden basis or dictionary a that
you care about
okay and it's also complete in the sense
that there are
and stand the dimension mm is larger
than n typically okay
and what you have given are random spots
combinations of these columns of it okay
so and I just drawn two columns here but
you can draw all these columns and they
are all sparse and there I mean so
there's randomness in this generation so
there's randomness both in where the
nonzero entries are and in the values of
these non zeros typically okay so now
you are you don't know eh you don't know
X you're only given Y okay and the goal
is to find a and X when you are given Y
okay so suppose you were given a and if
you're given Y then recovering each
column of X really corresponds to
compressive sensing but here you are not
given a as well but what you are given
up many samples and the hope is to
recover both a and X simultaneously so
you're learning both the hidden bases
and the representation the sparse
representation in this basis
simultaneously okay so this is the
problem any questions about the problem
or the setting so there are two
questions that you can ask first okay so
when is this solution unique when can
you recover a and X from what okay so
that's the identifiability problem and
the other question is can you design
polynomial time algorithms to recover
the dictionary of the representation
okay so now I've stated this problem I
mean both these problems are very
challenging and the way you usually deal
with this with both these problems is by
making distributional assumptions on X
okay so you always would want to assume
some kind of assumption on a you would
assume that the dictionary say the
incoherent satisfies a restrictive
restricted isometry property just
because even if you are given a to
recover X uniquely you need either
either incoherence or some such
assumption so we'll always be happy with
making an assumption about the
dictionary the unknown dictionary but
even to understand this problem of
identifiability and so and you usually
need to assume distributional
assumptions about X okay
so so what are the distributional
assumptions about X so here you can
think about this generator model for X
so you can split the process of
generating X into two parts okay so
first you try to figure out which are
the nonzero entries of X okay so you can
think about this distribution D s D sub
s which generates parts vectors which
generates K sparse vectors so it will
generate n dimensional case parts
vectors and this gives you the
distribution for the sparsity pattern
essentially okay so just assume that
every sample will have its positive
pattern generated independently from
this distribution so a simple
distribution to keep in mind it's just
that these are random
I mean uniformly chosen among all case
paths vectors so I mean yeah typically
you assume a nice distribution of this
form and the second process and the
second step of the process you now
generate the nonzero values for the
positions where you know for the
positions that you know are nonzero okay
so that is this value distribution okay
so you can think about the value
distribution for now it's just being
plus or minus 1 with Z equal probability
in general you may want to assume that
it's a symmetric distribution which have
some support in some intervals ok which
of I mean they should be bonded away
from 0 because you should know which
ones are 0s and which ones are non zeros
ok but for now you can just think of
them as plus minus 1 with equal
probability
yes so you cannot film so yes so now you
did a film that eat nonzero entry it is
drawn independently from this
distribution oh yeah in the vanilla
model that's what you're seeing yep okay
so you first figure out what the nonzero
entries of X at that is from this
distribution D sub s and then you just
draw the nonzero entries according to
the distribution okay just think about
it is plus minus 1 with probability 1/2
e it's a model clear the basic model
clear so now the I mean just so now each
sample is just generated from this
two-step process and we'll just use this
notation to denote the distribution
generating process for each column of X
and this is just done independently ok
any questions about this so dictionary
learning has been started for a while
and there have been a lot of nice
guarantees in the last 10 years
so these guarantees are mainly for the
following distribution where if you just
think of the support distribution is
again random case pass vectors ok it
doesn't need to be exactly random but
can we slightly there can be some slight
dependencies but essentially again this
think of them as being uniformly random
k sparse vectors and then the value
distribution for for this stock is also
just going to be radical variables
ok so plus minus 1 independently with r
already half each
so the first Whoville guarantee was
given I think was given by I mean
computationally efficient provable
guarantee was given by Spielman Etta
spin-1 Wang and Wright who showed that
you can actually learn the dictionary
when the samples all had sparsity which
was at most Rutten but there's one
caveat here which is that they needed to
assume that the dictionary was not over
complete which means so the very measure
over completeness is by looking at the
ratio between the number of columns and
the number
of dimensions okay they needed to assume
that the dictionary was square or thin
okay you really wanted to be fat so
because it's an over complete basis but
they needed to assume that Rho was at
most one which means that the number of
columns of less than equal to the number
of rows so the first of guarantees for
the over complete regime where I think
you do Aurora and Moitra who showed that
you could actually recover these
dictionaries even when case yeah for the
same range here is being root n less
than root N and this has a very nice
connection to detecting overlapping
communities yes yes so as I have stated
it here you can think about it as an ICA
problem except that as I will mention in
a little bit this these results actually
deal with you know can tolerate some
amount of dependencies for instance ICA
as far as I know will not be able to
handle the case when you know you can
think about the case when each
coordinate is nonzero probability k over
and each then it's completely
independent but if you think about the
vector the support vector as just being
exactly K sparse then you already lose
independence okay so it's already not in
the ICS setting but again you know all
these results at least the second or
results will actually work by relaxing
independence assumptions they they
actually worked with approximate
independence and they also work with
bounded independence because I am just
making it a little easier for the top
okay so simplifying it for talk it's a
good question yeah okay and then there
was this more recent work based on sum
of squares which will actually I love
you to build opacity which is almost n
but here you need to make some stronger
assumptions about the amount of over
completeness so the amount of over
completeness is only a constant and it
it degrades exponentially with the
amount of over completeness okay so
there are suite of nice algorithms that
handle this dictionary learning setting
okay so and then a
people have also try to get guarantees
for popular heuristics like alternate
minimization and so on but a lot of
these guarantees do use to still do
strong distributional assumptions about
X so both about the support and about
the values okay they are essentially
this that's a good question so the first
result was a quasi polynomial time
algorithm the second result I think was
a polynomial time algorithm as long as
sparsity is something else slightly less
than it so maybe it's n to the 1 minus
epsilon or maybe yeah I think if it is n
to the 1 minus epsilon you can make it
full Mountain I'm not sure I think you
should ask some of the other experts
here given four and a K being n / poly
log n K being n over poly log n so the
main thing that we are trying to focus
in this talk
using a semi random model is do we
actually need or do we actually need
these kind of strong assumptions about
the support of these vectors X ok so the
assumption is usually I mean that it's
run the support is random and the values
of random and a question is do we need
these assumptions about the support so
we use a several model to try to capture
this kind of robustness ok and a bowl is
to allow for almost arbitrary supports
for the columns of X as such okay
clearly this cannot work cannot be
completely arbitrary because you know
all your columns can avoid all your
entries of X can always avoid the first
column in which case you never see
information about the first column so
you of course need a little bit of
information but you can actually show
that yeah so right I mean okay so the
goal is to study this kind of a semi run
a model that will allow us to reason
about this almost arbitrary support
pattern index I mean it's more general
it'll be more general than the basics
part scoring model and I mean it'll also
be helpful in identifying when you can
hope for identifiability
I mean in understanding when you can
hope for identifiability what are the
minimal assumptions you need about
supports to get identifiability
and also poly time algorithms so good so
we wanna call us of X to be arbitrarily
the supports to be arbitrarily
distributed so no assumptions about the
support but of course it's not possible
because of some trivial reasons like
this browser you can come up with
slightly more interesting examples where
you know each column will have
representation but you can kind of align
them the supports nicely in such a way
that you can't hope to recover and X
okay good so but here's a thought what
if there was just a small amount of
random data okay so now maybe this
random data will actually make the model
identifiable and now you don't have
these statistical issues and your bolus
now to just get Polly the mountains okay
so let me go through the model a little
more slowly so you here's a generative
model for X now they think of beta as
being something that is extremely small
you can think of it as inverse
polynomial you have a bunch of samples a
few samples from this random
distribution for the supports okay so
beta fraction of the samples are going
to be from the random distribution for
supports okay and the rest 1 minus beta
fraction are completely adversarially
chosen so and these adversary lectures
and supports can actually look at the
randomness in the in the first few
randomly chosen supports okay now of
course all the samples you don't know
which ones have been randomly generated
and which ones have been adversely
generated they're coming in some random
order you don't know you don't know this
okay if we knew the random sample where
the random supports you can just use the
old algorithm with these things
and so so what's the process so the beta
fraction of the supports are going to be
generated from this D s which is this
random support distribution okay and the
rest of the 1 minus beta fraction of the
comments are going to have arbitrary
supports and now the values of each of
the nonzero entries are again going to
be drawn from this value distribution
independently of run okay so it's only
trying to capture I mean this kind of
adversarial nature for the supports the
values are still going to be completely
wrong so you should really think about
this as lot of samples with a few random
supports and most of them are being
adversarial okay so here's a simple
thing this everyone a model is
identifiable your wife's riding a tribal
well let's just try to identify a why is
a identifiable well you can just focus
on the random samples you don't know
which ones they are but they're there
okay so you can just focus on the random
samples and just from the random samples
is identified I think just because of
all these earlier works and now once you
know you can now recover all the columns
of X just by compressive sensing so
identifiability is not an issue in the
semi random model at all just because of
the few random samples that exist so the
nice thing about this model is that the
adversary and it's completely
overwhelmed the random portion and you
of course don't know which is a random
position which is the adversarial
support portion okay so now in aggregate
a lot of these statistics I mean in
aggregate the distribution the support
distribution may just look completely
arbitrary and for a lot of the existing
algorithms which actually deal with the
I mean the samples on aggregate they
failed because of this and another
reason why we don't have algorithms that
work in a small search is because we
don't have products relaxations that
capture sparse coding well okay so
the situation with matrix completion and
compressive sensing isn't really
applicable here any questions about the
model a is doesn't have to be incoherent
in there did you make that assumption
yeah yeah yeah if you know coherent
everywhere yeah yeah learning for
naturally from being coherent for
example the examples you show these or
is it okay I'm not sure yeah you're
probably mixed
I see but in sometimes if you want to
get a you need some kind of an
assumption perhaps not in coherence
perhaps our IP is a is a reasonable
assumption but you need some kind of an
assumption to ensure uniqueness of X
otherwise it's hopeless even if you know
a and you need that kind of assumptions
so what are the main result in I mean at
a high level we give a robust polynomial
time algorithm
I mean it's robust in the sense that it
works in the semi-random model and it
works up to sparsity a square root n
will go through the results more
carefully but it also gives you I mean
interestingly a couple of surprising
consequences when we are studying this
were said this way of looking at it also
helped us identify may helped us
understand some minimal assumptions
about the supports needed for
identifiability
okay so while we are talking about the
semi-random model and designing
algorithms for the semi Ida model if you
had go into the actual workings of the
algorithm we are able to show some very
minimal assumptions under which of the
supports under which it's identifiable
and in fact these algorithms in fact
gave better I mean better guarantees
even in the purely random model in
certain regimes of parameters so we look
at this okay so the first result is
result for the semi random model so
assuming that the dictionary is
incoherent so it's it's a it's let me
let me pass the result with you so
assuming that the dictionary is
incoherent and suppose you are given
polynomially many samples I'm not going
to care that much about what exact
polynomial it is from the semi random
model with high quality we can recover
both a and X and polynomial time up to
any desired accuracy okay so the
accuracy will this show up in the number
of samples provided the sparsity is less
than square over them so this is an
assumption that I've written it in here
but it's not really an assumption that's
needed so that's like a graceful
trade-off with respect to the spectral
norm of a and the spectral norm of a is
just a measure of the over completeness
so this is the polynomial dependence on
this which decays gracefully and that's
there from the earlier works as well and
note that K being less than or equal to
root n it's a barrier even in the poly
random model if you just have the
incoherence assumption that's with our
IP you can hope to do better
but just enjoy this option square root
em Nessebar e and we do match this Maria
yes we also have sparse structures and
in England oh no no it has to be sparse
vector so we crucially use the fact that
whatever samples are given have wholly
sparse columns yeah so it's not
arbitrary vectors it's all this plastic
yeah that's a good question
so a second result is actually result
for just a pure random model okay where
the supports are actually fully random I
mean it's random in the sense that will
describe in a bit so here we're gonna
assume that is our IP just because we
want to go beyond the square root n
regime and here we show that with in
polynomial time and samples we can
recover the dictionary up to any desired
accuracy provided the sparsity is less
than n to the 2/3 and so this leads to
algorithms in certain new regimes
because the result of Arora dermoid Rob
works for the sparsity being up to
square of n whereas the SOS algorithms
it goes up to n but then you need the
amount of over completeness to be a
constant we've here here you don't have
this assumption on the amount of over
complete okay so some of these results
are very incomparable in this context
yeah so just to give you a sense of the
results is just in a purely random model
and you know when I say random the
supports can't have some approximate
dependences well so our results can also
tolerate that just as the previous works
the supports you can think yeah I can
think of it as bounded independence and
approximate bounded it balance supports
okay so the result of Oregon Moitra
can go up to square root n I mean if you
think about it in terms of M which is
the number of columns its it has its
dependence you'll also lose just a
little bit in terms of the amount of
over completeness so that's measured in
terms of the spectral norm and the ratio
between the number of columns and rows
so these SOS algorithms work up to low
of em but then you need the amount of
over completeness to be a constant and
has goes up to M to the 2/3 but it has a
verse dependence on the amount of our
completeness then or rather gone Moitra
so it doesn't need to be constant but it
has a worse dependence so yeah and
different regimes these three results
I mean ya are incomparable and optimal
and certainly they're not optimal but
they're better than soda
any questions about this oh yes I'm
going to describe y'all good yes yeah
good question yeah so so yeah another
nice consequence is identifiability
result so we actually show
identifiability all the way up to lil o
of em I mean it's possibly going up to
little little o of n assuming just a
very weak assumption about the supports
the only thing you need about the
supports is that for every three
coordinates there should be at least a
few samples where all of them cook yeah
so of course every column has to occur
otherwise you don't have any information
about the column and in fact we can also
show that you can come up with instances
where you know every two columns
co-occur but I mean it's actually not
identifiable and but if you have this
triples condition that every three
columns co-occur okay I'm not least a
few samples then the model becomes
identifiable polynomial itself and yeah
right so but here we are assuming that
these are rather master variables here
and goes all the way up to Linnaeus
plastic okay good so let me try to
sketch the details of the algorithm in
the next ten minutes or so okay so the
two main parts of the algorithms are you
know we have a testing procedure and the
candidate generation procedure okay and
what is the testing procedure going to
do well the testing procedure assumes
that you are going to be given a unit
vector okay which is potentially a
column of the dictionary here we this
assuming that all the columns of the
dictionary are unit vectors okay I
should have mentioned this earlier so
suppose you are given a candidate vector
Z candidate unit vector Z your task is
to identify whether Z is close to any of
the columns or whether it's far from all
the columns okay so that's your task
okay
now this testing procedure yet so it
just outputs yes of ZZZ somewhat close
think of ETS just being won over poly
login so it's somewhat close to one of
the columns are it's far from all the
columns a second this is an is going to
be an efficient procedure and the second
procedure is just a candidate generation
algorithm it will just produce many such
candidate vectors see you just be
polynomially many of them and you just
run all those vectors through this
testing procedure and then you'll
identify the columns okay so two parts
to the algorithm so I'm going to mainly
focus on the testing procedure because I
think this is a nice take away from this
talk so yeah this is the testing
procedure again remember you're given a
unit vector Z you just need to identify
whether it is far from all the columns
are close to one of the copies okay so
here is the the TL statement let me not
go over it too carefully it's just gonna
say with very high probability whether
it is close to one of the columns are
far from all the columns and this
testing procedure will go all the way up
to order and sparsity okay so this
stretching procedure is solid all the
way up to order and sparsity and in fact
i mean i mean while it may seem like
most of the work is going to go into the
candidate generation process this
testing procedure is already fairly
non-trivial because this testing
procedure will work under the Triplets
condition and it will immediately give
you identifiability for the model
because you're going to get this testing
procedure to work with exponentially
small failure probability and now you
can just take an epsilon net overall
unit vectors and feed them into the
testing procedure I'll decide interfere
all the calls okay so this testing
procedure is already doing something
non-trivial because it will immediately
give you identifiability
okay and it works just another triplets
condition any questions about this right
so what's the testing procedure doing is
actually very simple okay so suppose you
are given this candidate vector Z and
let's just take one of the samples why
let's say Y is a times X okay now let's
just take an inner product
let's take the inner product between the
sample why and this candidate column Z
okay let's say suppose this candidate
vector unit vector Z was actually one of
the columns okay then you can just split
it out the sum Y inner product with Z is
exactly XJ times the inner product
between AJ and AJ that's one because the
unit vector plus summation over all the
other coordinates x i's times AI in a
product with AJ I'm just writing it out
so nice thing is it XD for us is only
going to be a the plus or minus one but
the remaining portion is really a mean
zero random variable because all the x
i's are a mean zero symmetric random
variables and in love low variance just
because of in coherence are are IP so
what this tells you is that if Z is one
of the true columns then all these inner
products are going to be either close to
one or minus one okay if XJ is 1 or
minus 1 R is going to be close to 0 and
this is really going to be the test so
if we if it were actually to call them
if you just look at the histogram of the
inner products between Z and all the
samples then you will really see this
kind of a histogram that all the inner
products have magnitude which is either
close to 0 or close to 1 but there will
be a non negligible number of samples
which have an inner product that's close
to 1
okay just from the random part or you
know you just need that column to occur
okay so this will be a testing procedure
you just look at the distribution of
these inner products and we will try to
just see if the distribution is bimodal
so if it is actually close to one of the
columns then it is actually by model in
the sense but if it is far from one of
the columns this is the hard part you
want to show that it's actually spread
out and why is it spread out well yeah
so this is the testing procedure and
once you you do this you can just if it
passes the checks you can just take some
averages over all samples and you can
amplified the accuracy and so on but why
does this testing procedure work well
the sound nerves really relies on this
key lemma which is actually a pretty
simple lemma it just says that suppose
you have some of these independent
Rademacher variables okay and suppose I
tell you let's say that the variance is
normalized to one okay suppose I tell
you that the sum takes a value which is
equal slice and some interval which is
close to t think of T as being much
larger than one with some probability at
least kappa okay then it is also going
to take a value which is somewhat
smaller okay let's say between 0.1 T and
0.3 T with some probability which is at
least some constant times couple okay so
if it takes a value which is in an
interval around T with some
non-negligible probability it is also
going to take a value the absolute value
of the inner product it's also going to
take a value which is somewhat smaller
with non-negligible T and non-negligible
probability as well okay and this is
kind of a challenge when Kappa is very
small if Kappa is large so you should
really think of Kappas large T is
somewhat small and you can just use
central limit theorems to argue that
this will happen with nermeen reasonable
probability the challenge is when Kappa
is actually very small
it's like inverse polynomial in n okay
and that is the kind of probability that
we are dealing with because our success
probability is K over m which is inverse
polynomial in N and here the way we
prove this is by using some kind of a
coupling argument there is a simple
direct coupling argument but you either
do this coupling argument or use central
limit theorem to show that this is true
okay so this will show the soundness and
soundness will argue that if it is not
close to any of the columns then you
will actually see spectrum you will see
it spread out between 0 and 1 so you
will see values between 0 okay so so
this is the
so that will be the support of that's
possible so it's not ends will come from
the central limit yeah yeah is that but
then these quotients may or may also not
be uniform and sinks so Center limit
theorem will also depend on the maximum
coefficient it could be somewhat large
okay so there's also the candidate
generation procedure which is actually
pretty simple
and just takes weighted sums of all the
samples but you do this weighting a
little more cleverly and I'm not going
to go into it
proving that this candidate generation
algorithm works is a lot more technical
because you need to then argue that with
some non-negligible probability you get
a vector that is somewhat close to a
column and that requires some
concentration bonds for low degree
polynomials of some rarely occurring
random variables and so that's the two
parts of the algorithm I'm actually
going to stop here and not going to go
into the clustering Gaussian mixtures
but clearly there is room for discussion
and she just come and ask me about the
random seminar model for clustering
gaussians you're interesting
[Applause]
oh good good good yes yes so I I did not
go into that so the test
so the identifiability result is not
computation it so it doesn't go up to I
mean we don't know I don't know an
algorithm at least our algorithm doesn't
work under just the triples condition it
meets the semi allemaal because we don't
have an algorithm that generates these
candidates under just the triples
condition no I don't think this is well
understood yeah yeah yeah yeah so yeah I
mean I think before this identifiability
result to the best of my knowledge the
only identifiability results that were
known we're through algorithms and I
mean some characterization but yes oh I
see okay that's you I mean the
dictionary you you will learn like for
example I think ya know you should talk
about this here oh yes okay let me let
me do that yeah thank you yeah well
there is the semi random GMM model where
I mean I can tell you about it offline
yeah well the the the punchline there is
that noids algorithm works under the
semi random model and this is based on
an analysis by Kumar and cumin it's a
really nice book and in this show set
under this semi random all four
gaussians Lloyd's algorithm works
whereas we don't know if a lot of the
other algorithm said you know for
planking gaussians works so that it's
perhaps an explanation for you know why
it's so successful I mean but I'm not
saying that the seminar the model is
super realistic or something in general
I think it will be very nice to
understand these kind of seven animals
for other unsupervised learning problems
and a costly problem that I don't know
is whether you can actually hit n
sparsity and either for the semi random
model or for the purely random model
when the amount of over completeness is
not just a constant
[Music]
[Applause]